let's talk about the u.s. presidential
election and how the parties are
choosing their candidates the incumbent
president Donald Trump has had as
challengers but no real threat he's
always looked like the shoo-in for the
Republican nomination
different story for the Democrats they
started with a record 28 candidates and
have been working their way down to just
one the one who's going to take on Trump
the u.s. system for choosing
presidential candidates is unlike
anything else in the world it's messy
and convoluted and not everyone thinks
it's fair so how does someone get to run
for the most powerful job in the world
you'd think that America a place that's
often held up as a beacon of democracy
would have a pretty straightforward
system to nominate who runs for
president
not even close if you're American and a
member of either the Republican or
Democratic Party you don't actually get
to directly pick the nominee at the
National Party conventions in July in
August your vote is used to guide a
person known as a pledged delegate and
it's their job to represent the will of
the party faithful at the convention
they're elected in what's known as
primaries or caucuses if you ask people
what's the difference between a primary
and a caucus unless they live in states
like New Hampshire and Iowa they have no
ID a multi-million dollar marathon of
smiles waves speeches and handshakes
which somehow contrives to put into
office the leader of the world's richest
nation most states hold primaries they
can be open to the public or restricted
to just party members or a bit of both
people at primaries cast secret ballots
for a delegate who they trust to vote
for their preferred candidate but three
states hold caucuses
they're basically informal meetings and
places like libraries or even living
rooms people argue in favor of their
preferred candidate and then they hold a
public vote one to three primaries and
caucuses go on for months and different
states have different rules
Republicans and Democrats organize them
differently too but this year the only
real contest is who will stand for the
Democrats so let's focus on how they do
it the Iowa caucus is up first followed
by these states and then Super Tuesday
when 14 states all vote on the same day
the US Virgin Islands are the last to
vote for the Democrats right before
their National Convention in July I
think by Super Tuesday in most elections
you pretty much know who the nominee is
gonna be some states that vote late
after Super Tuesday for example really
have no say in who the nominee is going
to be winning early in a sword if
they're able to generate the revenue
that you need to campaign
hard in these later primary states it
also gives you I think an air of
electability because it's shown that
you're a winner
and people like winners it's what they
call the momentum effect it happened
with Trump and other presidents too and
momentum can build as early as that
first caucus in Iowa Iowa has turned
underdogs like Jimmy Carter and Barack
Obama into winners but taking Iowa like
Pete Buda judge said this year doesn't
guarantee you the nomination because
this isn't just a popularity contest
it's also a numbers game bear with me
here at the Democratic Party convention
in July there are almost 4,000 spots for
delegates and a candidate needs a simple
majority to win simple so far right but
each state is allocated a different
number of Delegates for instance
California gets 415 New Hampshire gets
24 and those numbers are decided using a
formula that may include how many people
live in the state and how often they
voted Democrat but stay with me there's
another formula this one's at the state
level and it's used to work out how
those delegates are divided up between
each of the candidates it's as
complicated as it sounds in fact the way
that votes are added up can lead to some
pretty confusing results like what
happened in New Hampshire this victory
here is the beginning of the end for
Donald Trump
this year Bernie Sanders won the popular
vote in New Hampshire by more than three
and a half thousand ballots but because
of the way votes were calculated he put
a judge actually got the same number of
Delegates it was a similar story in Iowa
and it's all because of those formulas
state parties have try to weigh the
allocation of Delegates to even and out
between the less populated rural areas
and the more populated urban areas so
Bernie Sanders support is very high
among young people he could win a lot of
votes around major university areas or
bigger city areas but he's missing these
sort of smaller spaces where people
'changes able to pick up to get any
delegates the candidate needs at least
15% of the vote at a caucus or a primary
if they fall short of that threshold
they're out of the race the ones left
standing get to go to the party
convention
[Music]
the candidate needs a simple majority of
delegate votes to win the Party
nomination but if there is no clear
winner then we're into a second round
and that's when the super-delegates
step in unlike pledge delegates who are
elected super-delegates are senior party
members who get an automatic invite
these super-delegates are basically
party officials people high up within
the within the machinery of the party in
each individual state and they also go
to the convention just because it's a
great big party and everybody wants to
go this year there are almost 800 of
them and unlike the pledged delegates
super-delegates can vote for anyone they
want so they don't necessarily reflect
the party's grass roots and that bugs
some people in the United States where
we like the mantra of one-person
one-vote essentially what we have
allowed to happen is that one elite has
the power of 10 zones or hundred votes
depending on who they are and where they
are they want to be more thoughtful and
holistic about how they run this process
but I think there's still a lot of work
to be done on how this process is
organized and also on how this process
is made intelligible to the general
public after the conventions wrap up the
Democrats and the Republicans will each
have their presidential candidate for
the Democrats in particular this whole
process is more than just picking a
candidate it's about deciding the
party's future direction
there's obviously aside that per Sanders
worn wing who wants to to go when
directions that are pretty radical for
the United States there's a more
moderate wing that wants to sort of stay
a little bit closer to the center
because they think that's the the only
way that they're gonna end up winning
the general election and that's the
ultimate goal
winning the presidency but that process
isn't straightforward either when the
November election comes around people
will be casting ballots for members of
something called the electoral college
those people choose the next president
of the United States that's a whole
other episode
[Music]
if there's a story or a topic in the
news that you want to get your head
around send us your ideas in the comment
section wherever you're watching this
video I promise we read them all I'll
see you next week for another episode of
start here
[Music]
you